hello
welcome everybody we are gonna get
started very soon
welcome
very welcome
you're tuned in right now we're gonna
get started very shortly welcome we're
gonna be talking about career projects
today
all right thank you all for joining
today we're gonna be talking about
career projects which are located in
your career portal and these are
designed to help you kind of get
prepared for your job search and
preparing to land jobs potentially in
the nanodegree programs that you have
signed up for
so those once again those are located
within your career portal where you can
also schedule a session with one of our
career coaches myself included so just a
quick introduction my name is Brett
Ellis I'm a career coach here relate to
Udacity I started a couple of weeks ago
and I've been having coaching calls
since then I'm really excited to be
working with you all so if you do have
any questions throughout this broadcast
feel free to type those into the chat
and then we'll be monitoring those I
won't be answering them as they come in
but I'll have time after we go through
some of the career projects to answer
the questions that you all have so to
get started I want to kind of walk
through the rest of the broadcast so
we're gonna go through each of the
individual career projects that are
available to you all why we use those
and why those can be beneficial to you
I'm going to go through the resume the
cover letter the LinkedIn and the github
and then at the end of that I want you
all to send any questions that you might
have and we'll do kind of a live Q&A
there at the end and then if you have
any further questions that we were not
able to answer I would like for you all
to potentially schedule a coaching
session if you need a little bit more
help with that so the first thing that I
want to talk about is the resume career
project and so the resume is important
because a resume is really a marketing
tool it's a document that you can use to
showcase your previous experiences that
relate to the jobs that you're looking
for
so for a lot of you these may be
previous jobs it may be some volunteer
experience it may be your involvement
with a professional organization
different things like that there are
going to go into your resume and really
it serves to showcase your ability to do
the job that you're applying for and do
it well so if you want to think about it
your resume can kind of be like a
proposal for the job that you're
applying for and so one thing to keep in
mind with your resume is that you really
want to make sure that you are tailoring
that resume for the different positions
that you're applying for you don't want
to have one resume that you send out to
every single job that you're applying
for because they're different processes
in place through the companies that
you're trying for that can sometimes
filter out those resume keywords and so
that is called an applicant tracking
system and it's also referred to as an
ATS and so those filter out different
applicants based on the keywords from
their resume and the job description so
that's why you'll want to make sure that
those are tailored and make sure that
your resume is unique to the positions
that you're applying for so if you take
some time to work through that resume
project on the career portal it'll give
you some advice on creating the document
in the different sections that you need
to have it will also give you some
resources that you can use into creating
your own resume so once again that
resume is going to be really important
because it is kind of the the main
document that employers and recruiters
are going to look for when you're
applying for individual positions that
you're interested in so if you do have
any questions specifically about the
resume I would highly encourage that you
go through that career project first
spend some time going through the
modules and the different resources that
are provided to you and then create that
document and then if you have any
further questions about that or maybe
something was unclear or you just didn't
understand it you can feel free to
schedule a coaching session with myself
or Angela or other career coach to kind
of walk you through some best practices
and advice on writing a resume
so if you do have any questions about
the resume project feel free to type
those in as I shared before I'm going to
be going in answering those questions a
little bit further towards the end but
just to kind of recap your resume is a
document that you use to apply for jobs
and you're going to be filling that
document with some of your previous
experiences that are going to relate to
the positions that you're applying for
and you want to make sure that that
document is tailored because you're
going to be targeting different roles
and responsibilities with each different
position that you apply for so for
example if you're applying for a data
analyst job at a agriculture company
that's gonna be very different from you
applying for a data analyst position
with maybe an educational company so
you'll want to really take a look at
that job description and those roles and
responsibilities because they will be
different sometimes and you would like
for your resume to target a lot of those
specific roles and responsibilities that
are unique to that company as well as
that specific position and another thing
to think about when you're writing your
resume is that you really want to focus
on highlighting results and achievements
because for employers they're looking
for people to solve a problem and if you
just purely list out a bunch of
different roles and responsibilities
that may not showcase to employers how
you can problem solve so you really want
to highlight some of your major
accomplishments as well as some
potential projects so even with the
Udacity nano degree program that you are
completing or may have already completed
you can go and also showcase some of the
projects that you've worked on there so
for those of you who may have may our
changing careers so going from one
industry to a different one and trying
to use your nano degree as a tool to get
to that point your Udacity projects are
really great to showcase on your resume
to highlight your ability to perform
well in that new role so once again if
you have any questions about the resume
project feel free to send those in I'll
address those towards the end of this
the next career project is going to be
the cover letter and so a cover letter
is a document that you write to really
appeal to the specific position and kind
of cover some gaps that your resume may
or may not have been able to cover so
with a resume it's pretty much a listing
of different roles and responsibilities
and achievements a cover letter is more
of a targeted more personal letter where
you're actually writing out and
providing a little bit more context for
your qualifications as well as it being
a great opportunity for you to address
any potential red flags that might pop
up for an employer so a good example of
that may be if you are a career changer
and you're going from one industry to
another industry a cover letter is a
really good opportunity for you to
explain why you're making that career
change and then also tell them why your
previous experience may be beneficial
for you transitioning into a different
field so that career project is located
in your career portal as well and can
help you really create a good letter for
you to explain your candidacy for that
role and and once again it's a little
bit different from the resume because a
resume is more so a listing of the
different jobs that you've had and a
cover letter is a more so targeted
document for you to explain why your
previous positions are a good fit for
your future employer and so a couple of
tips that you can use to really make
your cover letter a little bit more
engaging are listed within that career
project within your career portal so I
highly recommend you take a look at that
and learn at least how to write a cover
letter not every employer is going to
ask for one but it can be helpful for
you to know in case you do have to
submit one so when you are asked to
apply you do have to submit a cover
letter you're not going back and then
trying to learn how to write a cover
letter it's good for you to learn how to
do that now so if they do request one
you're ready to write it or you're ready
to go so
that project is also located within the
career portal and it's a really good
tool for you to learn how to use so that
you can really explain some of the the
unique things about your experience that
may make you more qualified for a job
the other great thing about a cover
letter is it can also give you an
opportunity to share a little bit of
your personality your resume is pretty
cut-and-dry professional document
you're not having a whole lot of fun
with that your cover letter could be an
opportunity for you to share a little
bit more about why you're passionate
about your industry for you to
potentially share why you got into the
field that you're looking to go into or
you can explain you know I'm making a
career transition and I've decided to
take on Udacity courses to better
prepare myself to work in this industry
so your resume doesn't oftentimes
provide you with an opportunity to
really do that and a cover letter is a
really great tool that you can apply
with your resume to address some of the
gaps that your resume might have or some
potential red flags so as you're
applying for jobs try to put yourself in
the position of somebody who would
actually be hiring for the job that you
want as you're reviewing your resume and
that mindframe think about what
questions might they have what potential
red flags might pop up for them to say I
don't know if this is gonna be a great
person to work for us those are things
you should anticipate and hopefully try
to address up front either in the resume
or the cover letter and sometimes that
can be really difficult to do in a
resume so being able to tell that story
and address some of those potential
issues in a cover letter is a really
great opportunity to to write that cover
letter so even if one's not required it
can be really helpful for you to include
one if you have a non-traditional career
path or you may be changing careers from
something a little bit different from
what you actually want to do that's a
great way for you to provide context and
explain to them why you might be looking
for that role and why you feel like
you're qualified once again there's an
assignment located within your career
portal for you to go
and complete that and learn how to
properly write a cover letter as well as
submit that assignment so as far as the
resume and the cover letter goes those
two are not required career projects so
those are things you do not have to do
but can be really really beneficial for
you to do now so that you can learn how
to do it while you have some support
from the Udacity team your mentors as
well as us as career coaches if you
don't take advantage of that now and you
wait a couple years and then you want to
learn how to write a resume or a cover
letter you might not have the resources
available to you to help provide you
with some of that so I would highly
recommend doing it they're not required
but it can be really beneficial for you
to go ahead and learn how to do that as
well as receive some feedback on that
so the next career project I want to
talk about is github so github is
becoming more and more popular
especially in the tech field and for
those of you who are enrolled in more of
the programming courses that's where a
github is gonna be really really
important for you so github is actually
required for some of the nanodegree
programs and you can actually find out
in your program syllabus whether or not
you need to complete the github project
and and what steps you need to do in
order to submit that so once again that
github assignment is also located in
your career portal and it's a great
opportunity for you to learn how to get
started with github or to continue using
it so on the side of the employer's
white github is important is because
they can actually go on to your profile
and see what types of projects you have
been involved in they can go in and see
what types of things that you're working
on individually as well as the different
projects that you may have contributed
to and the really cool thing about
github is you can contribute to projects
with people across the world and so if
somebody's working on a project that's
related to something that you're
interested in you can go ahead and kind
of find ways to add to what they've
already started and go back and forth
and potentially share it with some of
your other classmates work next
there the other thing about github that
employers look for is there's a kind of
box on your profile a little bit towards
the bottom that showcases looks like a
calendar or a schedule and it can show
employers how active you are on github
and so for a lot of employers it's
really appealing to see people who are
actively using github who are on at
least every couple of days or maybe at
least three days a week something like
that so they can see that you are making
a conscious effort to always improve
your work and that you're spending a lot
of time coding because as I'm sure
you're aware things move very quickly
and they want to see that you're keeping
up with trends and that you're coding
all the time so that you're prepared for
when they may be looking for somebody to
to fill a role that they have open so if
you're not using github and it's
something that is required for your
program I definitely recommend that you
start sooner than later so that you can
start to show that you've been active
consistently and even after you get a
job that doesn't mean that you should
stop using github it's it may it may
also be infused into part of your job
but it's also a great idea for you to
continue contributing to projects and to
continue using github because at that
point you may have employers who reach
out to you and you may not have to put
as much effort into your own job search
because people are going and seeking you
out for the the work that you're doing
in your free time so once again with
github it is required for some of the
nanodegree programs not for all of them
and if you're unsure about whether or
not it's required for you make sure you
check your syllabus so that you can see
whether or not that's a project that you
need to get started but even outside of
it being a Udacity requirement for some
programs it can be really beneficial for
your career as well as your job search
because employers are going to be
looking at that and seeing what types of
projects you've worked on as well as how
often you're actually spending working
on projects and spending doing some
coding
work along those lines as well the next
one I want to talk about is LinkedIn and
LinkedIn is my personal favorite I love
LinkedIn because it is not only a place
for you to kind of get a job it's a
place for you to learn it's a place for
you to connect with other people in your
industry and it's a really good place
for you to have like a one-stop shop for
all of the work that you're doing so if
you use LinkedIn correctly and create
your profile - a way that it showcases a
lot of your work you can almost use your
LinkedIn profile as a portfolio of sorts
and so I highly recommend that you go
through and do that because LinkedIn is
required for all of the nanodegree
programs so whether or not you want to
do it you should because it's it's
required and it's super beneficial it's
it's the reason why I got my current job
with Udacity is somebody reached out to
me on LinkedIn because they saw that the
work that I was doing on there I could
give story after story about how
LinkedIn has positively contributed to
my career but if you go through that
career project which is also located in
your career portal it does a really good
job of walking you through the different
types of things you should be doing to
create a really good LinkedIn profile
and then when you get that submission
the same way with the other career
projects you'll get some really great
feedback on how you can improve that to
really get the attention of employers
because at the end of the day we are
wanting to be employable most of us are
taking these nano degree programs either
to do better in our job or to get a new
job or to explore a new interest and so
Lincoln is a really great opportunity
for you to go and do that because as I
mentioned before you can connect with
people so let's say for example you are
looking to make friends or build a
network of other people who work in your
industry that also work in your city or
your geographic location you can
actually go on LinkedIn
and search for for example front-end
developers you can search for that and
you can also filter it by location and
you can find people who are located in
your geographic area and potentially
connect with them in person and some of
those people may have access to jobs if
you're interested some of them may just
be doing very similar things to you and
you may be able to collaborate on
projects in person as well as online so
LinkedIn is a really great tool for that
and then the last thing that I would
just mention about LinkedIn is that
you'll want to make sure that you're
active on there similarly to github so
employers don't look as closely at your
activity on LinkedIn as they would with
github but being active on LinkedIn and
actively contributing to people's posts
if you're creating your own posts if
you're writing articles that showcases a
certain level of credibility and can
really help you stand out as a subject
matter expert and so for me I put out a
lot of content about career coaching and
providing tips on resumes and using
LinkedIn effectively and so I'm assuming
that that was potentially what drew the
attention to my profile for this job as
well as the last job I got was through
LinkedIn and those were opportunities
where people reached out to me because
they saw what I was doing on LinkedIn so
I highly recommend LinkedIn because if
you use it effectively and you're
posting content you're engaging with
people you may even be able to eliminate
your need to job search if you're doing
it well and you're encouraging people to
come and look at your profile to then go
ahead and reach out to you for potential
interviews if they're interested in that
so if you have any questions about the
resume cover letter github or LinkedIn
assignment make sure that you're typing
those in just to kind of recap the
resume is a marketing document a job
search document that you're using to
showcase your experience as well as to
show them why your past experience
relates
jobs that they're looking for that one
is not required but we recommend it
that's why it's there we want you to
learn how to do that as a student of
Udacity we want you to know how to learn
how to write a resume so that you can be
effective in your job search the other
thing the next thing is the cover letter
cover letters are great for you to fill
in some of the gaps that your resume may
not have been able to answer it's also a
great place for you to showcase some
personality as well as tell some of your
career story to get somebody interested
in more than just your job
qualifications get help them get to know
you a little bit better and why your
previous experience relates to what
they're looking for so the cover letter
as well is not required but also
something that can be a great
opportunity for you to take some time
and learn from as well as explain some
things that your resume might not be
able to explain the third one was github
and so github is required for some
programs but not all of them so make
sure you're checking your syllabus to
ensure that it is or is not required so
that you can take advantage of that and
github is great for you to contribute to
other projects to also go on frequently
and showcase to employers that you're
highly active in practicing your skills
as well as contributing to other
people's projects and then the last one
is LinkedIn LinkedIn is online social
network platform for professionals and
really focused on careers and helping
people connect to other people in their
industries it's a really good place for
you to have a lot of your experience in
one place so it kind of serves as an
online resume but also allows you to
upload projects and kind of serve as a
portfolio for you as well and then the
last thing with LinkedIn is to make sure
that you are actively engaging through
liking and commenting and sharing
people's posts as well as creating your
own posts and potentially articles so
that you can really establish yourself
as a subject matter expert in the fields
that you really want to excel in and
want to be known for LinkedIn is
required for all of the nanodegree
program
so make sure that you're doing that and
taking that seriously because once again
if you are using LinkedIn correctly
employers will reach out to you to
interview instead of you having to
always apply for jobs and reach out to
employers so it can really put you in a
powerful position where if somebody is
reaching out to you you may even have
the potential to demand a little bit
more money if you're highly sought out
or something like that so it's a really
good tool to utilize if you're looking
to connect with people get known in your
industry and also find a job or just
passively build your brand and your
personal brand online while you're still
working so those are the four career
projects we're gonna do some questions
right now so I'm going to take a look
and see if we have some questions about
the career projects okay so we'll start
with this one how to show group work
without a degree or a job so in terms of
working in groups or teams a resume is a
really good opportunity to do that so
what I recommend instead of just saying
that you worked in groups talk about a
specific project that you may have
completed with the group and really do
make it make an effort to showcase the
results that came about because of that
project so instead of listing something
like worked in a group to complete this
project you could say we increased the
efficiency of this process by
collaborating with our group to do this
this and this something like that would
be a little bit more appealing but your
resume is a great place to put that
information so that employers can see
that you have worked in groups before
but also as I mentioned previously if
you are in a program that is is
requiring github for Udacity you can go
in there and actually contribute to
other people's projects which is going
to be really appealing to some employers
especially because they're gonna want
you to collaborate with other
people in groups across the world
sometimes and so that can be really
helpful to showcase to them that you've
done that in the past let's see what is
another question how to put the courses
we took in Udacity in a resume as a data
analyst so in your resume you should
have a section for education and you can
use that section to list out Udacity as
well as the nanodegree program that you
are completing or have completed another
thing that you can do is include in that
same section some of the major projects
that you worked on in your nano degree
program and to take it a step further
you can even add links in your resume to
link to some of the results from those
projects that you've completed and I've
seen that on a couple Udacity student
resumes and I think that that's a really
good idea because if you're able to get
that in the hands of the employer or
able to send it to them they can go and
actually get a visual representation of
your work instead of you just saying
that you did something you can list out
your Udacity nano degree program some of
the projects that you worked on and even
linked to some of those projects so you
can showcase the relevant experience
that you have for the jobs that you're
looking for that's a really good
question let's see next question
[Music]
what types
should I put in my portfolio still
struggling with this because I don't
know what to showcase so that's a really
good question for a lot of you a
portfolio is gonna be really really
important and even for those of you who
work in industries where a portfolio may
not be expected it's always beneficial
to have a portfolio it's always
beneficial to be able to showcase the
work that you've done versus just
telling people about the work that
you've done so when you're thinking
about what types of content to put into
your portfolio that's really going to
depend ultimately on the types of jobs
that you're looking for so if you're
looking for a job as an Android
developer your portfolio should include
you working on developing Android apps
and if you have not had a lot of
experience doing that I highly recommend
that you find opportunities to do that
for yourself a lot of students that I've
spoken to are waiting for people to
provide them with experiences when you
could be creating these experiences for
yourself on your own so one
recommendation that I have is if let's
go at that same example if you're
looking to get a job as an Android
developer do some things for free if you
have to so maybe you have a friend or a
family member who has a business maybe
you can create the app for them that
helps them as well as helps you to add
something to your portfolio so you
always want to consider the types of
roles that you're looking for you don't
want your portfolio to necessarily be a
listing of every single thing you've
ever done that can be overwhelming for
somebody to review and it's best if you
can create a portfolio that's very
targeted towards the industry that you
want to work for with a lot of different
samples of work that relate to the jobs
that you're looking for so in thinking
about what you want to add to that look
at some of the job descriptions and look
for some of the things that they asked
for and if you have relevant projects to
showcase those are the types of things
that you should be including in your
portfolio and then once again if you
don't have a lot to show for that
include some of your Udacity projects
and volunteer to just create
those opportunities for yourself because
chances are those employers are going to
want to see things a lot of them aren't
just gonna take your word for it
with the nanodegree program they're
gonna want you to showcase some of the
projects you worked on as well as some
of the things that you've done outside
of that program okay let's see I don't
have a degree in computer science but I
have a couple of nano degrees how likely
am I to get a job in the area that's a
really good question so nowadays it's
not as important for you to have a
traditional college degree if you can
showcase that you're capable of doing
the work that is required some of the
biggest companies in the world now Apple
and Google and Facebook are not
requiring college degrees for some of
the jobs that they're applying for so
that's good news for some of you who may
not have gone the traditional route of
going to college but have taken the
opportunity of taking a Udacity course
because that nano degree is going to
showcase to them that you have a very
in-depth knowledge and that you spent
several hours and sometimes months even
years developing a specific skill so you
also have to have some confidence and
the things that you've learned in your
Udacity program but once again it's
gonna be extremely important for you to
showcase those projects and those
results so that's a common theme that
you'll continue to hear me say is to
focus on the results and showcase to
employers because at the end of the day
Google is not gonna hire somebody with a
computer science degree with no projects
versus somebody with a Udacity degree
and a portfolio full of projects that
related to what the things that they
want to do so a college degree is not as
important as it used to be but that
doesn't mean that just the nano degree
is gonna get you the job either you have
to be able to showcase what you learned
and the things that you have created and
the things that you have worked on after
taking the time to learn that
information from your nano degree that's
a really good question
let's see what else do we have should I
start working on my resume even before
finishing the front-end nano degree
course that's a good question as well so
I would say you should get started on
working on it but I wouldn't say that
you should try and finish it before
you're done with your nano degree
program because if you're able to get
started it makes that it makes that
process a lot less overwhelming once
it's time for you to actually go and
complete it so for the most part your
resume is going to consist of things
that you've done in the past not things
that you're you're currently doing that
will be featured on it but the majority
of it is going to be things that you've
already done so you can take some time
to start working on our resume and to
start brainstorming and thinking about
from my past experiences in the past
jobs that I've had or the past volunteer
roles that I've had or the past whatever
that you've done how do these jobs
relate to front-end development so let's
say for example you were a graphic
designer before you can start to think
about what aspects of this role did I do
that relate to front-end development and
start to create your resume with that
you don't want to just list out all of
the different things that you've done
that don't relate to that position
because employers and recruiters are
going to want to see that you took the
time to create a resume that is tailored
for that specific industry and you're
basically telling them the story that
you want them to hear because the job of
a recruiter is to make assumptions about
whether or not you can do the job so you
want to showcase to them even if I
wasn't working in a related field the
things that I was doing are transferable
and the things that I was doing have
prepared me to do well as a front-end
developer so going back to the question
I think you should start I don't think
you should pressure yourself about
finishing it until you're actually
completing the degree but you also want
to get to a point where you're not
finished with the degree and then
preparing for your job search and then
job searching it should be something
that you do kind of continuously
throughout so
you may have your resume finished before
you completely finish your front-end
nanodegree program so that when you are
finished you can jump right into your
job search and not have to go through
that process of getting all of that
information ready if you have any
further questions about that I would
highly recommend that you complete that
career project or at least start working
on it if you have any other questions
feel free to schedule a session with one
of us as career coaches and we can help
you plan out a strategy or create a plan
for what you should be working on and
when you should be working on it but
that's a great question as well okay
let's see I have a long employment gap
as I was caring for my elderly mother
she passed at the end of January what's
the best way to deal with that so first
of all I'm sorry to hear that that's an
unfortunate situation one of the things
that you can do to address an employment
gap is to highlight that you were
working on something during that time
it's also a good opportunity for you to
potentially mention that in your cover
letter because you're not going to say
something like that on your on your
resume you may write a cover letter and
mention that you had to take a break
from work to take care of a family
member but you're excited and you're
ready to get back into your career and
you've taken this Udacity course as a
way to prepare you for that so as I
mentioned before your resume is great to
showcase some of your work experience
but it's not always able to share all of
those ins and outs and unique situations
that may have come about so a cover
letter is a really good opportunity for
you to address some of those potential
issues that may come up but at the end
of the day if you ever experience a
resume gap or you can anticipate that
you're going to have a gap always do
your best to try to fill that with
something career related and I know that
we don't always have the time to do that
but even if it's as simple as you taking
an online course or you taking a nano
degree program in the spare time that
you do have it will it will serve as a
much
better platform for you to showcase to
employers that yes I had to take this
time off because I had personal issues
to deal with but I also did not put my
career completely on hold I was taking
time to continue bettering myself as a
professional okay let's see another
question this question says how to get a
job at Google as a data scientist so
that's a good question I'm sure a lot of
people have that question
so one of the things it's good number
one that you know a company that you
want to work for a lot of times that is
one of the first things that we
recommend is that you do research to
find companies that you really want to
work for now that you know Google is one
of the companies that you want to work
for you should also know that Google is
one of the most competitive companies in
the world to work for so that means that
you have to be top-notch you have to be
ready to go you have to have career
projects that are related and for a lot
of jobs sometimes you have to even have
connections and so one good way to build
connections in to kind of get people on
your side in the hiring process is to
conduct informational interviews which
is something you may have heard if
you've been on any other calls webinars
or workshops that we've done but
basically an informational interview is
an opportunity for you to connect with
somebody in your industry who may be
doing something that you want to do so
for you that may look like you
connecting with somebody who works at
Google one really good way to do that is
to utilize LinkedIn and so you can
actually search Google or you can search
for Google on LinkedIn filter it by
people and see the different employees
that work at Google you can even have a
step further and say add data analysts
to it or data science to it with Google
so that you can find people who are
actually working as data analysts or
data science experts in Google and then
you can go to their profiles and reach
out to them and say hey I would really
love to work for Google I
just recently completed a Udacity
program learning this information is it
possible for me to talk to you about
your experience working there or for you
to provide me some advice on how I
should apply for this job
because you know for us as career
coaches we can give you really good
information about how to job search and
how to connect with people but we're not
going to be experts on how to get a job
within specific companies those people
who have already done that are going to
be great resources for you so that can
be an opportunity for you to reach out
to them and learn how they were actually
able to accomplish that and maybe
provide you with some advice for you
completing that process the other thing
that it could potentially do is give you
a foot in the door and give you an
advantage over everybody else who's just
simply applying for those jobs you may
be able to indicate that you were
referred by a certain person or you may
be able to connect with that person and
ask that they forward your resume to the
person who's hiring for the job so it
can be really beneficial especially with
those large very competitive companies
to try and build connections with people
there one thing that you want to avoid
is if you're reaching out to people for
informational interviews or for jobs the
last thing you want to do is say hey I
noticed that you have a job can you help
me get it or hey I see that you have a
job opening for a data analyst I'm gonna
apply for it can you forward my resume
that's a very transactional approach and
you're not really investing in that
person to try to get to know them it
just comes across as you purely using
them to get a job there and nobody
really wants to help anybody who's using
them so go the route of trying to learn
more about their experience ask them for
advice and see if you can actually build
a connection with them so that when it
does come time for an opening or are you
applying for a job you have somebody
that is a genuine connection and not
somebody who were you at you were using
to get a job okay what other questions
let's see I'm finishing my I'm finishing
a nano degree at Udacity in the middle
of another what would be the perfect
timing to start job searching so that's
up to you so it depends on your
situation it depends on what
you want to be looking for so I'm not
sure exactly which nano degree programs
you're working on so that's also going
to contribute to your job search but
ultimately that depends on your specific
situation do you need a job right now
are you currently working and just
looking to develop your skills so when
you do want a job search in the future
that's gonna be up to you and what
you're looking to do and your current
situation that's gonna depend on every
single person who's on this call when
you job search is gonna be up to you but
I think if you are going through and
finishing a program now it can be
helpful for you to at least have some of
those career projects completed or close
to completion so that if you do complete
a new nano degree program at that point
you're not going in and creating a brand
new resume you're going through and
updating the one that you've already
worked on or you're not going in and
changing your whole entire LinkedIn
profile you're just updating it with the
new Udacity program that you're working
on but as far as your job search that's
gonna depend on your specific situation
and if you want to talk about that a
little bit more one-on-one then I would
recommend that you schedule a coaching
call ok how can I ran myself in order to
start my own business as a new developer
I don't really want to go the freelance
route I want to step up as an LLC my
background is in accounting so that's a
really good question so if you want to
brand yourself and start building a
business as a developer I think that
there are a couple of things that I
would recommend but I would highly
recommend you use some of those
platforms like github and LinkedIn
because a lot of people are going to be
looking to those for some of the
projects that you've worked on so I
personally have have started my own
business doing something very similar
career coaching and Linkedin has been
essential in me developing a brand and
really becoming an expert so as I shared
before if you're on LinkedIn one of the
great ways to become an expert is to
write content and share things that are
relevant to your industry so if you're
looking to start a business as a
developer you should be posting content
about development and you should just
share tips you should share projects
that you are
you should tag other people who you know
who are also doing those things so that
people are starting to see that and they
start to see you and they see oh this
person is a developer they're clearly
good at what they're doing because
they're always sharing information and
they're always educating us on how to be
a better developer or how to do these
things and so people are going to be
naturally drawn to your profile and then
if they for example need something
created for them they may reach out to
you because they may not know anybody
else who does it and is good at it so I
would highly recommend that you focus
specifically on kind of those two career
projects your resume and your cover
letter is not gonna be extremely
important for you when you're trying to
get clients outside of a regular job
they're going to be looking more so at
your portfolio again so regardless of
whether or not you're trying to get a
job or you're trying to start a business
everybody wants to see what you've
previously done especially because if
they're looking for things like that
they're not gonna be cheap projects so
I'm not gonna want to spend a couple
hundred dollars and just trust that this
person is gonna be able to do the job
I'm going to ask to see previous things
that they've worked on so if you develop
paps I'm gonna want to see apps that
you've developed before if I need an app
for my own business so once again you're
gonna want to have a lot of different
projects that you can showcase because
people are gonna ask whether they're
employers or they're looking to hire
somebody to do it for their business or
their personal needs okay let's see
another question about employment gaps I
touched on that if it's on your resume
you can potentially even showcase that I
wouldn't spend a whole lot of time going
into depth about why that gap is there
but it may be you going back to school
and maybe you taking care of a family
member and maybe you had a child and you
had to take care of that you can go a
couple of different routes you can leave
it blank or you could just simply list
that that's what you are doing so that
they're not confused about why there's
an empty space on your resume but then
your cover letter is a really good
opportunity for you to go in more depth
and address that situation okay if
you're looking to make a career switch
is it best to include previous
experience in your portfolio projects or
to leave your old life behind
so I touched on that a little bit but I
think that you're going to you're going
to have certain things that are related
but you have that's why you have to know
the industry that you're going into and
you have to be very critical when you're
going through job descriptions and
reading through and looking for those
things so in the example that I shared
before you know if you're applying for a
front-end developer position maybe you
have some background in graphic design
or you know creating websites even if
it's not through maybe maybe you just
used like a Squarespace or something
like that to create websites it can
still be helpful for you to showcase
different things that you've actually
done so it's gonna be up to you and kind
of having that discernment between
whether or not this is related or
whether it's it's not related so you you
need to be critical when you're going
through those job descriptions and you
need to know your industry if you feel
like you need a little bit more help
with that specifically I would
definitely recommend that you reach out
to your mentor to see like what types of
projects would be really helpful for you
to showcase outside of the ones that
I've listed so that you can determine
whether or not the previous projects
that you've worked on are relevant and
should be included in your portfolio but
once again your portfolio should not be
an exhaustive list of every single thing
you've ever done you want it to be
targeted and you want it to relate to
the jobs that you're looking for good
question okay I want to become an
Android developer please help me how can
I learn if you want to become an Android
developer your first step is to learn is
to study and potentially sign up for you
city chorus not sure if that person who
asked that question is involved in that
nano degree program but I highly
recommend it if you are looking to go
into that route you always want to have
some sort of education or experience or
expertise to showcase that you're able
to do those things because employers and
recruiters are not often going to just
give you a chance to do a job that you
don't have expertise in in doing ok
let's see should I put my small projects
on github once again I think when you're
thinking about what projects to include
what things to include in your portfolio
what things to include on your resume
you have to be doing the research on
your own to know what employers are
looking for in your specific industry
you're going to want to look at job
descriptions even if you're not job
searching right now just spend some time
looking at job descriptions for the
types of jobs that you want to have and
start to think about does it make sense
for me to include this on here because
another thing that might happen is let's
say for example you want to go into a
front-end development or something like
that and all of your portfolio and all
of your projects are related to graphic
design people are going to reach out to
you for graphic design they're not going
to reach out to you for front-end
development because all of your work is
showcasing that industry and that
specific type of work so you have to
know for yourself for your industry and
for the specific jobs that you're
applying for what types of projects are
gonna be appealing so I think that that
goes for github LinkedIn portfolio
everything ok let's see so
this question says I have 12 years in DW
/bi on Microsoft technology how can I
get a job on advanced technology like
data engineer what type of project I
need to do it
nano degree to get the experience so
with with the with the nano degree
programs that you're completing a lot of
those are kind of included within that
experience so obviously those are going
to be helpful but they may not be enough
they may not be enough to get you a job
with certain employers so you're going
to want to make sure that you're
completing all of those and being very
intentional about those projects so that
you have great experience to showcase
but it may require you to do some
additional work on your own and so if
you feel like the projects that are
included are not comprehensive enough to
help you land jobs once again I would
recommend that you either look to do
things for free or try to find people
who may potentially pay you to do some
freelance things or things on the side
so that you can really help build that
portfolio and really showcase your
ability to do the things that you're
looking to do that's gonna be a common
theme and that's one of the reasons why
we are doing this conversation about
career projects is because these
projects are designed to help you
showcase the experiences that you do
have as a nano degree program is really
focused on education and you get some
experience to really go in and do that
through the projects but you're gonna
want to do as much as you possibly can
to gain experience in the industries
that you're looking to land jobs in and
that's going to really depend on your
specific situation so if any of you have
questions or want to figure out a better
strategy for creating a resume or really
anything that we've talked about today
if anything is unclear or you have other
questions that we weren't able to get to
make sure that you can you reach out to
us as career coaches to schedule
one-on-one sessions or you can email
career - support at Udacity
if you have some quick questions that
you need answered but if it's a little
bit more in-depth then you may want to
schedule a coaching session with one of
us so thank you all for attending and
tuning in I hope this was helpful I
highly encourage you do all of the
career projects but not all of them are
required but they can be helpful for you
and really learning how to progress in
your career and really land jobs so
thank you all for attending and once
again if you have any further questions
you can email career - support at
udacity.com or try to schedule a session
with one of us career coaches in the
same location where your career projects
are located thanks